hey what's up do it are you friendly f
you too [ __ ] oh I forgive you buddy
because it's that time of the month
April finally brings us a decent Daisy
update because the recent experimental
patch earlier this month tease us with
some big picture elements that didn't
seem to cut it this month's point four
four update we'll get some upcoming
fixes but for now wash those hands and
put on that bit because it's suppertime
first up a new mouse control system
implements one to one movement and
control meaning no more sluggish turns
or limitations just you and your mouse
so adjust the sensitivity to your liking
another big one allows you to throw some
Oh mom can't spaghetti again well don't
eat it stupid chuck it ah but hey what
mama don't know won't hurt are your
jeans slowing you down well loosen up
those legs with tracksuit pants look out
on your left ah later nothing can stop
you now well except for Heights actually
warning track pants do not prevent
broken legs and when that does happen
well you know what you gotta do I can't
take it anymore I can't live like this
hey you what did you witness that what
what is what they do to jump to dead no
I did not can you please give me your
shirt and how about some new weapons the
pickaxe find yourself a construction
helmet taking off that shirt and hit the
town hey guys you know where I can find
the weight room but what's really on
everyone's mind is the crossbow and it
looks pretty sweet you can customize
this beast with scopes like the ACOG for
some easy pickins but something's
missing oh yeah bolts arrows are so rare
that you'll come across multiple rifle
setups before you can even find one
arrow even when you do get some you'll
be afraid to fire a shot yeah you can
shoot one on the ground and pick it back
up but use it on a zombie their corpses
vanish along with your bolt before you
even have time to reach them meaning the
whole point of a crossbow doesn't seem
even worth it but hey so I'm
new real estate opened up it's called
common off yeah and she is a beaut how
do you get there it's easy let me walk
you through it if you remember how to
get to churn a Apple onna the town added
from last month's patch what you're
going to want to do is head Northwest
from there cross the road just hike up
the mountain and down and you're you're
gonna make a left heading west on that
road just follow that until you reach
the inners wait okay okay okay yeah so
go back up the mountain just walk south
through the woods up the hill walk
through the clearing and there what is
this place oh oh so it turns out it
hasn't been added yet but it's supposed
to be added in the coming patch other
than that you get binoculars to scope
out runways and the farmers market
opened up fresh zucchini for everyone
hmm which is of course followed by it's
stupid no-good piece of worthless
counterpart rotten zucchini touching
back on the experimental servers it was
hinted that were soon due for a doubling
of server sighs I managed to play some
of those matches with up to a hundred
people running around just killing
hating each other you guys are not
friendly they're trying to beat the crap
out of me it was weird yet where there
is hate and frustration in dayz you
don't need to kill me you don't need to
do it and go get out all right I'll get
out out of excellent day there is love
and disco fever sometimes you just need
to unwind like burlap sack guy here you
know what everyone needs to be more like
burlap sack guy I mean sure Daisy is in
perfect Sheree has glitches and hiccups
but don't let that stop you from having
fun be more like burlap sack I just try
to be more like home oh that's it for
this month's patch see you next time
Oh